bonnet de bain lunettes de piscine les
frites à la main c'est parti au centre
aquatique de saint cyr l'école sept
enfants s'initient gratuitement à
l'apprentissage de la natation vous
allez devoir tenir la frite avec les
mains d'accord la crise sanitaire et la
fermeture des piscines ayant énormément
bouleversé l'apprentissage de la nage
vers marine a décidé de lancer
l'opération les petits nageurs on cible
particulièrement les enfants issus de
milieux modestes
parce que ce sont eux qui sont les plus
exposés ils n'ont pas forcément accès
facilement aux établissements comme les
nôtres et à des cours de natation privée
donc leur proposer ses solutions de
rattrapage gratuite c'est très important
apprendre à se protéger du danger de
l'eau maîtriser les gestes élémentaires
et développer les bons réflexes voici
les principaux objectifs sont basées
c'est beaucoup la flottaison
la propulsion donc c'est pas sur le dos
sur le ventre l'immersion ça après celle
au principe de la natation qu'on essaye
de voir au fur et à mesure et pour les
faire progresser et à la fin de la
semaine chaque enfant a reçu un diplôme
nautique garantissant ses aptitudes on a
appris à nager on appelait à nager sur
le dos mais je savais déjà ma gestion
les dos et et on devait mettre la tête
sous l'eau jeter c'était trop bien ouais
que puis l'a appris j'ai appris comme
pour une étoile on a joint de temps
soleil et le premier qui fait pas de vue
l'idée est miné du jeu au total dix
mille enfants en école primaire vont
pouvoir bénéficier de ces stages de
natation gratuitement en france au
centre aquatique de saint cyr l'école le
prochain se déroulera pendant les
vacances de pâques